[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting
we are talking about sibling dynamics
and personality tropes specifically
the whole birth order thing we actually
put a prompt out to you
uh saying exactly that let's talk
sibling dynamics and personality tropes
on ear biscuits tell us how being the
oldest
youngest middle or only child
influence who you are feel free to dish
dirt on your parents
and siblings too yeah so we're going to
group this conversation
by uh the type of sibling
that they said they were and you know
we'll we'll get in where we fit in but i
think it
it we should probably just go ahead and
establish what we are
yeah well between the two of us we
represent two different things
and between our families we represent
all the categories
i'm a younger child you're
you're one sibling of two you have one
other older brother one older brother
cole
his name is cole not spelled like the
like the rock
it's not a rock it was originally but
then he changed it out of embarrassment
just kidding it's a family name c-o-l-e
uh age difference is
uh age difference is about three years
uh
but school was
he was a he was a senior in high school
when you were a freshman would you call
that three years
i would call that three years three
years yeah supposed to be in high school
together and so to about two and a half
years in age and about three years in
school
yeah i'm an only child
yeah surprised the one of the only
the special you know it
if it ain't broke don't have more kids
i'm
i'm like just pristine and a perfect
little baby
just like an only child would say yeah i
know of course i'm
i'm totally joking i've got maybe maybe
there's some bitterness that i'm going
to uncover once we get to
discussing my experience i did have half
siblings for a while
well i had a had a a half not a half
sister i had a step sister
in the house for like
grade school and she was in high school
and then by the time i was in
third grade-ish mom got a divorce it was
just me and mom
she was not she had i mean
she might have had prospects to make
more babies we haven't discussed this
prospect but um i mean i remember a few
she had some boyfriends i remember a few
boyfriends
the brown you remember the brownie
points brownie points we always talk
about brownie points guy
he's he stuck out the most she was she
was dating him
yeah his name was walt i don't know how
i remember
that by that time i was i must have been
16 because i would i would
come younger than that when they started
dating i do remember being 16 and
driving home
and mom wasn't home because her car was
wasn't under the carport
but his car was there and he was sitting
on the stoop
on the stoop i'm pretty sure he was
drinking he had a six-pack
yeah i remember this story i wasn't
there
i just remember my mom telling me she
was like now
link got home in walt was sitting on the
stoop drinking beer
he had a whole six-pack that's i just
remember i mean that's just the start of
the night and i was like nice
netflix and chill well in our world it
was like
he may be dangerous you know what i'm
saying that's how i thought about it and
and i was like it was weird for me
it wasn't like my mom wanted to make
sure that i was okay
with her dating somebody walt was a fine
guy
you know there was there was nothing
wrong with the guy he was i mean
i seem to remember him a bit of a tool
like i mean yes there was a time when he
he dropped us off at the party and on
the way there my mom was in the car too
but it was me and you
being dropped off at like a probably
what was like a eighth grade or nine
ninth grade makeout party yeah the best
and he he started talking about brownie
points
and i still didn't really understand
something but i'm pretty sure i got some
that night
you got some brownies i racked up on
brownie points uh
she also dated okay this is just in
terms of medicine who my mom
dated this has nothing to do with what
we're going to talk about happily
remarried
can you just table that conversation
let's table that because you've got
three children but i'm basically an only
child and then i got three children so
you got older middle and younger and
i've got two boys that's why we had
three older and younger
just to see what it was like i knew
about the middle child tropes and so we
didn't have a middle child
on purpose no i think you forgot to have
a middle child
uh and our kids are that's what happens
with middle children
five years forgotten so five years apart
your kids are like two years apart each
right like two windows a little bit more
lando's eleven lilly's 18 lincoln 16.
whoa so like five so you got like two
and then five
yeah okay anyway
so before we get into some of the
the uh some of the responses
we did a little boopity boop research i
do want to just just up top here
a lot of the the responses that we're
going to give
are going to fall into what you may
already have in your mind as a trope
or as what you think is established
science about
some of these stereotypes a middle child
you know the different sibling order
but just to kind of get all that out of
the way without getting into it
if you take all the studies
and try to condense them down to just
some sort of predictable
guidelines or understanding of sibling
order you guessed it it's indeterminate
it's inconclusive there's lots of
conflicting data uh
and and i and i'm not saying that it it
doesn't exist and i'm not saying that
sibling
order doesn't have an impact on who you
are but most of the studies seem to
indicate that
once you become an adult these things
the other things about your personality
kind of went out and it isn't
what order you were born in that
determines who you're going to be for
the rest of your life
i don't know if that's comforting or
upsetting to you based on how you've
thought about your life
of course once you get into the specific
dynamics of the specific people that you
grew up with
that has a tremendous impact on who you
are as a person but you did but just to
boil it down to birth
order is um you know
it oversimplifies things and science is
not gonna and i think i
put you down i actually i am um
i'm resistant to this even though this
is what the science shows or doesn't
show
yeah i know i'm resistant to it because
i've always
thought about my children and well
really
not as much my kids i think my kids kind
of go against this in some ways but
me and my brother i think hit some of
those tropes
and i've always thought that me compared
to you hit some of the tropes of
grew up with kid grew up with siblings
grew up as an only child
yeah i've always attributed some other
things about you and some of the things
about me and our differences to that
and maybe i just been wrong all along
let's start with oldest and work our way
down that way
uh you know we're saving the best for
last and i'm talking about me
the only child
exactly starting with jay duh
that's jada layfrost jada lee frost
oh isn't being the oldest horrible
the trial kid they test it all out on us
then the younger ones have it easier
this might be the most
universal trope
i think the next one we'll read is it
advised for that position but yeah
you know i mean certainly when lily came
along
you know you got this first child you
want to do you want to do everything
right
and especially you know there's people
here
having babies like here on earth kevin
kevin's wife just had a baby yeah uh
they're doing great
and they're at such a you know i was
just reflecting they're at such a
different point
in their lives than we were when we
started having
full of hope but they're older you know
kevin's older he's wiser he can you know
he's i anticipate he's not going to wig
out in the way that i did when i would
like i just i still felt
kind of like a newlywed well because a
couple of years ago a few years before
23 years old yeah it was a few years
removed from teenagehood so definitely
with us as
young young parents of a first and
eventually
oldest child is that you want to get
everything right and you
there was all these rules and systems in
place in the neil house
for lily and i think that we were trying
a lot out
on her that then yeah it absolutely
everything that we experienced with lily
impacted what we pivoted to
with lincoln or with lando i mean
you know it's i'm trying to think of an
example
that doesn't have to do with like
punishing the kids but like
you go from i mean
is it i brought up spanking on good
mythical morning it's
like i guess that's really controversial
like i guess
but and it is it is today it is yes and
lando was never spanked
lily was not spanked a lot but there was
but it was something that was taught
and that was part of a system and
you know it was there were certain
ways that you could go about it that
were
you know not abusive i think was what
was going on in our minds
i'm not saying that spanking across the
board is abusive i'm still not going to
say that
because my experience with her was that
it was
i felt like we were we were doing the
right thing we changed our minds
over the next two kids well by the time
we got to lando really we changed our
minds
but um lily didn't lily didn't need a
lot of
spanking anyway so it wasn't like we
really wrestled with it
we just kind of moved on and it wasn't
we moved to time
outs pretty quickly even with lily i
will say but with timeout
timeouts didn't work with lincoln and
then
with lando they did culturally uh where
we
not just in north carolina but again
where we the culture that we were
a part of in north carolina it was uh
you know spare the rod spoil the child
right and so basically everyone
was again we're talking
spanking on the bottom that's
we're limiting it to that um but then
there was this
sort of emotion in emotion like not not
out of anger not out of anger
right basically honestly the way that i
was brought up right like
my brother and i were both spanked it
was um
again my wife is the one who's done the
research in the reading on all this
stuff and
our wives are the one that do that do
all of the reading about parenting and
most of the parenting let's just be
honest
um yeah but uh and jessie has strong
feelings about this
basically saying that she she feels
she's completely sort of flipped her
perspective on
the role of the of spanking now
i um but just to say that i think that
there is definitely a spectrum of how it
can be administered right i'm not we're
not here to defend it and we're not here
i'm
why don't you here we are yeah i'm sorry
i i brought it up again and i in this
like
it's such a controversial thing that i
just don't even want to
but it's a good illustration of like if
you got your first child and she gets
spanked and then your third child never
gets spanked i mean it is a good example
of like how things
change and you you learn and well and
we're sorry but if you're the first
child
in one way or another in every way you
inform what happens with every other
child
they're moving forward and i i mean i
guess what i can say is it seems like it
sucks to me
the same thing was true in our household
and locke
was the one who was you know we were
undergoing
sort of our own personal evolution we
were our world view was being turned
completely upside down as our kids grew
up which is a whole different
a whole different thing that studies
will be done about our
our kids in this generation because
there are so many people whose world
views are changing right now
uh but setting that aside if you just
isolate that the way that we
punished lock both the frequency the
intensity
was definitely we were more lenient with
shepard but it
but it wasn't just because he was a
younger child it was because we were
changing the way that we were thinking
about parenting
and i could say that thus far and
discipline specifically there doesn't
seem to be a nota
a notable difference between the two of
them in that particular it's it's more
determined by their disposition and
their personality and less the way that
we are interacting with them
that's that's another thing that i think
has shifted for me
over time and i do think that the
science shows this is that
one of the sort of the ideas from the
culture that we came from
is that the parents have just the weight
of responsibility like
your kids i mean literally just bible
verses
that talk about if you train a child and
up
in the way that they should go you know
they will not depart from it when they
become an adult
and so there is actually a lot of shame
uh in in a lot of you know sort of
religious circles
when your kid sort of departs from that
or your kid
ends up being a hellion when they grow
up because
that means that you did something wrong
and i think that
i'm kind of coming to the conclusion
that like yes parenting is very
important but a lot of it is
kind of based on what you model not what
you say and also a lot
based on their disposition so that's a
little bit of an aside
and we were very focused on
even at the beginning based on the books
that we were reading like i remember
there was a book called shepherding a
child's heart
which i thought was very helpful i don't
remember the specifics of it now so i'm
not
recommending it now it was so long ago
uh
you know 17 16 years
ago but being focused on not just
getting a kid to
robotically respond and do what we want
the kid to do but understand
our children's hearts and who who they
are
and and and how to shepherd their heart
into blossoming as a
a loving individual and yeah like a
well-developed um
and and probably yeah at certain times
it boils down to just well-mannered
kid so but this wasn't true
i can't think of another trial some
other things that i
changed this wasn't true for me as a
child though
my it's almost like
i mean my dad was so consistent he was
so consistent
and my mom both of them were so
consistent
in what they thought and how they
parented from the beginning
until we left and it i don't
i never perceived the noticeable change
between the way that i was treated in
the way that my brother was treated
now so you so you don't think cole would
say he was the trial
and then they adjusted for you that may
have been happening but i never sensed
it
right and looking back there's no i
don't have any tangible examples of that
but for my kids
it's more of a 100 yes the
the leniency that we that we operate
with towards
um shepherd is definitely higher than
what we did
with locke and it's based less on i mean
i think it's a combination of just like
your little
you only have so much attention other
now there's two of them i can only
devote so much attention to them but
also it's just
i this didn't seem to work that well
they didn't he didn't listen to all he
didn't listen
he didn't do all the stuff that we asked
him to do so why don't we just
let the second one just be be a little
bit more free
taking care of mama tweeted back at us
as an oldest child that stereotype of
the firstborn being more cautious and
law-abiding totally true in my
experience i would even go so far as to
say
that i did a terrible job of breaking in
my parents before my sister got old
enough to break the rules
yeah like i said we we had lots of rules
and
uh parameters uh
for lily and i think that you know you
you grow up in that world and you're
like okay this is
the you know she responded to it so she
became the
uh reliable um
rule follower that then you know
kind of became as as lincoln and then
lando entered the scene
she was she was sometimes we treat her
like a third
adult a lot of first uh oldest children
responded and said that like they're the
third parent
like the the babysitter all the time
have
being given substantial responsibility
to take care of the siblings
and to follow those rules and to be
reliable
and and counted on is something that and
then
you know practically it plays out that
way but the negative aspect of that is
bossiness right like i see i seem to
remember
lilly going through like the bossy older
sister phase which
she definitely seems like she's well out
of that at this point
everything that her that we said to her
then she was like oh here's a younger
kid in the house now i can say it to
lincoln
you know i can and and can you fault her
it's like
she's reinforcing the things that that
we would have said to lincoln too
we've had to say i can't tell you how
many times we've had to say
this is not quite as common as it was
maybe even a year ago but for several
years
jesse would have to say locke
i'm parenting right now you know like
because
shepard would be getting in trouble for
something she would be saying something
i would be saying something
and then locke was like yeah and and
he's like he gets in on it
right he's like no no no that's not your
role your role is not to
parent but specifically we're talking
about with this whole rule follower
thing
again i think this is where it comes
down to
your specific personality and we're
going to like we keep promising it we're
going to do the enneagram episode right
but yes
um so kids kids are different and
recognizing uh like the fact that locke
as i've said before
is more of a challenger so if when he
sees a rule
he questions the rule it's not just like
the rule exists you follow it
the rule exists he his immediate
response is
why does that rule exist is that rule
actually good
does that rule intend what it is what it
says that it's intending to prevent
right
uh whereas shepard is more just like he
i wouldn't say he's a rule follower but
i wouldn't say that he's a rule breaker
either i would say that he's kind of
just his own person
and if the rules suit him he'll follow
them and if they don't he won't
but again so this isn't this doesn't
seem to be
true in my with with my kids i don't i
wouldn't say this one's a rule follower
this one's not
and right maybe it's a little bit
i mean you how would you perceive me and
my brother
growing up you could you might
perceive this a little bit i mean
the con the consistency of discipline
that you talked about does resonate like
i mean
yeah we we would get into trouble and
you would get a punishment and then they
would call my mom
and then tell her and then if i was
involved to the same degree
i would just get the same punishment but
if they didn't have the conversation i
wouldn't get any punishment at all
but so i knew that like you were getting
this there were always
um repercussions for you
so and yeah so
some we would break the rules together
but i would you know
we'd have to reach some momentum and you
would have to overcome a lot
but versus me and mike but you weren't
my brother yes so
if you were like so i think you're the
same i mean i think his personality
is probably probably more of a rule
follower but i think because of the
discipline in your home
you your actions were
similar yeah i think we're kind of the
same
in this regard i i think that compared
it's more about them
the parents yeah i would say compared
with like personalities the general
population
as kids both of us
were what you would call a rule follower
now we're we
we may have been mischievous right yeah
let's do some prank calls or whatever or
let's listen to
in my brother's case it's like i'm gonna
i'm gonna get
the most explicit gangster wrap
cassettes available
and then let my brother and his best
friend listen to him
yeah but still am i going to do the
things that the adults in my life expect
at least
externally yes am i going to be known as
a
as a rebel kid no and that was that was
the same for both of us so this this
this trope didn't really hold true let's
move on to the middle child before we
forget
okay i i was tempted to skip
middle children entirely and then at the
very end realize it
as a joke and then just end the episode
but
um let's not do that let's talk about
middle children but first
let's sell that t-shirt yeah this is the
official
cotton candy randy savage oh yeah
daddies uh i don't think that we can
say that it is it is not randy savage
no it's it's it's cotton candy randy but
it's definitely inspired by
the spirit of randy savage yes which is
out there somewhere
and which inspires us constantly go to
mythical.com
to get that and all of your apparel
needs met
you also have an amazon store with
different stuff amazon.com
mythical all right so
let's move to youngest child
you get it see i still did it all right
middle child
cyrus cole responded
i'm number six of nine kids that still
happens
parents still have like nine kids these
days it could be a farm
it must be a farm but but no but now
there's with factory farming
the families don't so this is not a farm
what is it
i don't know i don't know parents want
our audience
i mean when chrissy and i first got
married and like
we had we were friends with families
that had a lot of kids and we just
thought that was
we'd go visit them or like chrissy would
keep babysit the kids sometimes
and it would just seem so exciting i
mean we thought we were going to have
like six kids
that was that was crazy it that's crazy
talk well
you you uh you wised up yeah it only
took three for you to wise up
yeah it really took two for me well
after the second one
i mean we had quite a negotiation before
before uh
making the third happen because i got to
name him lando
he exists i had to reiterate that story
to him the other day i don't know why he
didn't know that i was like you know you
wouldn't be here if your name wasn't
lando never complain
your mom agreed to letting me name the
third child if it was a boy
and then we went for it when i said when
she said okay
i will agree to lando as a name he likes
his name though
cyrus says i'm number six of nine kids
being in the middle
left the impression on me of being
easily
i forgotten i think that might just be
because you're one of nine children i
mean of course
this is a trope though left at stores
church etc and my favorite not getting
picked up from soccer practice multiple
times
no cell phone it was quite traumatizing
as a kid and took years to heal
dang cyrus thanks for sharing i'm
sorry that you were traumatized by being
left alone at soccer practice multiple
times
um yeah you got the you but in general
this is the thing middle child just gets
lost in the mix
not necessarily literally literally
lincoln
the middle child in our home is you know
he's
he's quiet he's not going to be the
first to like
come into a room and just take over the
conversation
uh whereas both lily and lando
will do that you know i'm here and i'm
assuming nothing was happening until i
showed up
or but but lincoln you'll just
you realize he's been there on the couch
for like a while he kind of
he kind of slips in and slips out i mean
especially over this past
year there's a lot of slipping into his
room and into his world of video games
and connecting
connecting with his friends right via
his headset
and screen right um but i've noticed
that he does this
thing where um
well i'm actually getting to the next
one so i'll i'll wait on that but
i'm trying to have we left him anywhere
not not not physically i mean i i think
that uh
again i can't speak to this because this
doesn't exist in my family
either one like the one i came from or
the one that i currently have
um but i am interested in if you think
that this
this uh teresa's comment yellow sun 11.
i'm number four of five kids and i'm
definitely a people pleaser and try to
keep the peace
my default is to suppress my feelings
and desires as unimportant and instead
defer to my siblings and others wishes
especially noticeable and annoying when
trying to decide what's for dinner
well with lincoln the one exception is
what's for dinner
that is my opinion about that is the one
thing that he's he's going to be the
first to suggest
hey what are we going to have for dinner
i got an idea we need to get hot chicken
from this place so we need to get this
type of chicken from this place or hot
chicken from this other place it's like
he he's
obsessed with that um but do do you feel
like
he's ever been a peacekeeper between
lily and lando um
he is he doesn't settle arguments
between the two of them but what he
does is he doesn't ruffle
feathers he knows how to work with
within
me and christie's demands like if we're
like
clean your room or hey your his job is
to take
out the trash and to move the trash cans
back and if i tell him to do it
he's learned whenever i have a plan or
even if it's something like hey
you know what this afternoon i think
we're going to play
we're going to play a board game as a
family he's learned
that the best thing to do is just to say
yes
like if i have one of these type of
ideas
even though it may not be what he wants
to do he knows that like
i'm so excited about it and that the
right answer
he knows what the right answer is and he
will say it but then
behind the scenes and practically he
he'll do
he can kind of finesse it to get get
some extra screen time out of it
or you know it's like i'm like hey we're
going to play
he he's in there on the screen i go in
there like hey we're going to play a
board game in like an hour and he's like
okay i'm like it's just so refreshing
because the other two they're like
there's always a negotiation well i got
this plan or i'm this and i'm that i'm
sure he had
he has things that he would rather be
doing and wants to do but he knows
the right answer like it makes it a lot
easier to move forward and then by the
way an hour from now
they're probably going to be wrapped up
in something else and it'll end up being
two hours
three hours we may not play at all and
i'll just be in here
you know you can come get come get me if
you want to do it but he just
he has this like zoomed out perspective
that like
the conflict and the drama
is just not for him you know and and so
that's sometimes what we'll be like
having a dramatic moment as a family and
you look up he'll be gone
it's just like it's just not worth it
that could just be
that could just be his disposition it
could be like both of my kids
again but it's but it is true if i open
the door
and say and i could be like
we're going to have a circus
at our house and everything that you've
ever wanted will be available to you
they'll be like well i've got plans like
all you got to do is have a suggestion
as to something that you want to do
and my kids will respond with why they
don't want to do it
it's almost like again i again i it's a
knee-jerk response
two out of three that's the experience
in my home too so
yeah it could be but you don't you don't
see him
settling arguments between the two
between lillian
and lando no i seen the negotiator
no what i see him doing is just like
smiling and kind of laughing at it like
shaking his head
right like he's always like i'm i'm not
in this fray
like it's not i you know he prides
himself on a low
living a low stress life staying on the
fringe of things
you know well i mean i would go with the
flow what i would have said
not just about middle children but
definitely like in cyrus's case with
being
six of nine kids i have to believe and
again this is and we're gonna we're
gonna jump around a little bit here
because
i'm gonna get your response as an only
child to this because
my the one thing that
makes sense to me and i don't know again
i don't know what the science says about
this it just seems
logical is that the larger
the family the more you had to learn to
be
deferential and accommodating to people
in your space
it might be you had like just something
as simple as if
you shared a room with someone growing
up
you are going to be a the way that you
defer to people
in the way that you see your personal
space and the way that you see your
items and your and getting your way is
going to be different than somebody who
was by themselves
and i've always thought that that's why
you are
really particular about a lot of things
and when you think oh yeah when people
try to
take you in a different direction it's a
big adjustment because you didn't have
to accommodate anybody
and i had to do that a little bit with
having one brother but somebody like
cyrus who's
from a family of nine you could talk
that guy into anything right
probably i mean in other words we're
going to test it cyrus
flexibility like you i would think that
the
size of your family not in every case
has to have some correlation to your
personal flexibility
yeah it's asserting your own preferences
or not or deferring and expect
iterations
and sort of having an expectation like
if if your preferences
always won then you're going to
have a bigger problem with your
preferences not winning as an adult
right or wrong uh yeah i think so
because it's it's yeah it's a it's a
shock to the system
when you ha you know if just yeah
absolutely
i don't i i don't know if there was a
like when
when i left home and went off to college
and we became roommates
that would have been the first test of
like oh i'm living in the same room with
somebody
um i don't recall us having
arguments about that at that point i
feel like the reason
that it's worked mostly well it might i
mean there may be like things that are
that are mildly annoying to me but
i feel like the reason that most of that
has what we in fact we were talking to
to mike mike mccarthy the other day
and we were talking about the fact that
we were high school uh college roommates
and he was like oh and you're and you're
still friends that's the amazing thing
is that you live together
during college like that's a huge test
of friendship yeah i think a big part of
it
is most of the things that
you are particular about in a living
space
i kind of just don't care like how cold
is it in here
i don't know i don't really care make it
the temperature that you want you know
what i'm saying
like i don't have an equally strong
opinion about a lot of those things so
i would just say like where should this
poster be where should this couch you
had assertive parents
and you had an older brother and i had
i had myself right and so i so i just
tend to be like
all right lane's going to have an
opinion about where this couch is and
etc
and and i don't have an opinion about it
and so why didn't
he just make the decision about this
yeah hannah batch
said i'm an only child and my fiance is
a middle child of four
and it's perfect i'm used to getting my
way
and he's used to letting other people do
what they want so
yeah so in our dynamic it does work i
mean if you were
if you were a firstborn that would be an
interesting test if we were
if we were both children if we were both
only true we wouldn't be sitting at this
table right i don't think that yeah i
don't i don't
i think that wouldn't there'll be there
would be no testing and i tend to be
really i tend to be a very deferential
person when it comes to
a whole slew of like you know
what things look like what things feel
like
living situation bathroom i tend to be
very deferential about all that stuff
i'm but there are things that i care a
whole lot about but they tend to
it tends to be a pretty narrow spectrum
of things that i care a whole lot about
and and i kind of put all my energy into
those things
you know what i'm saying like i i don't
even know exactly what those things are
but
i think that's one of the reasons that
this has not been like a
lasting source of conflict for us yeah
we're in a fortunate birth
order situation here let's go to
youngest children
so this is this is you so we're on to
you
uh rachel black said i'm the youngest
out of my sister
and i and i get away with a lot more
but also don't have the high
expectations put on me
which can be both good and bad
i mean we kind of talked about this a
little bit uh for me this was not the
case because my parents were super
consistent
it is kind of the case with our kids
but i think it's it's a combination of
factors
but without a doubt like what shepherd
is allowed to watch
what shepherd is allowed to say
yeah what he's allowed to do
is significantly significantly more
lenient than
i mean like you know we again
we come from a conservative evangelical
background
early on when lot was really little and
he wanted to play with pokemon cards
like jesse had questions about that
because of the evolution aspect
of pokemon cards yeah that that's how
ingrained that that idea was is like
i don't know about that because i know
that those things evolve
right just to give you a little slice of
where we come from
that that one's more extreme than the
harry potter example which is also true
it's like harry potter really took off
before
before we were having kids but we were
too old to be into it ourselves
but eventually lily got into it but it
wasn't
i mean lando is reading harry potter now
and has been for a year or so but when
lily was you know 9
10 11 years old there was no harry
potter in our house
right because of the witchcraft stuff uh
and
because i wasn't into it and it was a
residual of that
witchcraft stuff that was just like
practically speaking we're not gonna
but now if i went to shepherd's room and
he was reading the adventures of satan
and his demons i'd be like are you into
that
i mean right i'm just i'm just saying i
completely
again i i'm not scared of any of that
stuff i don't believe that it's a
reality so
um in other words like and we're not
going to push our kids towards something
by trying to
but by setting up the goads for them to
kick against yeah i think that's another
part of our philosophy
that has shifted is
you know don't don't let fear
drive set up walls yeah
you know it's more like let's have open
conversations about things and
you know if if they're legitimate
dangers associated with things
then let's really get into the details
and discuss
it so it's not about just a blind
rule or all of a sudden there's a wall
here and it's like no questions asked
and well yeah and to clarify i'm using
the example of
the adventures of satan as demons as a
purposely inflammatory thing that i know
is going to upset some people because
you know i like to do that but
um it's kind of like he doesn't have
that book that he does not have that
book
it was just a a funny example but even
if you think about like let's just talk
about the little nas x thing
for a second right with in the satanic
panic that's happening around that
i do think that you know rewind ten
years
and if my ki my kid neither one of my
kids is
you know would consider themselves much
of a little nasdax fan but they're both
aware of
the montero video and the controversy
that is that it's causing
and i there was a time where i would
have been afraid to just let them
watch that and for us to have a
conversation about it
now i understand that the whole point of
the video
is to cause the panic and cause the
reaction
for branding purposes that's what
lonazex was doing from the very
beginning and a bunch of people took the
bait and got very upset about it
i mean it was hook line and sinker they
just took the bait and got upset
about the video and the shoes that had
blood in them right
a lot of people um and i think that now
it's just like hey can't we have
can't we step back and just it isn't
like oh kids you can do
and say whatever you want to it's not
that there are no rules it's that
the things that are important and the
things that are actually
going to be um potentially harmful and
dangerous to them
let's have real meaningful conversations
about them and let's kind of say that
hey
all these things that we thought might
be dangerous and harmful actually
aren't and we can still have a
conversation about why some people see
it that way
so so with our youngest kids there's a
lot more
leniency in our in our parenting because
because we're of evolving you know our
our perspectives are evolving and
there's
you know it's there's so much that you
want to protect your kids from
in every single day there's so much more
out there that they can be exposed to
that could be damaging
um so you you've got to be even more
strategic
in choosing the right battles because if
you battle everything
it's it's there's a sense that it just
won't work and
i think that there nothing will stick as
a very
very broad generalization there are
there are two types of kids right there
are the kids who are going to do
the subversive transgressive things and
there are kids who are not going to do
them
and whether and if you are the kind of
kid who is sort of wired to do the
transgressive things and you grow up
in a really conservative atmosphere you
are going to break bad and you're going
to
break bad in a real big way a lot of
times right
but if you're a super and if you're a
rule follower and you grow up in that
you might just get out okay and just be
a rule follower for the for the rest of
your life
or you might get fixated on it like i
mean with lando
he's at a stage right now
and you know it's so we're we're
figuring it out
and what it means and kind of tracing it
back
and figuring out what our path forward
is but like he you know he gets worked
up about anything that feels like
it's a violation of a rule not a not a
like a societal rule whether it's
you know a curse word or even like
uh anything that's offensive or
embarrassing like a fart
and again that's not something that came
from you no he's very
he's very sensitive so for him it's like
we're trying to
help him understand a grid
through which to interpret what what is
actually dangerous
or what is what it what does it mean for
something to be offensive
you know um or not
so that there's not unnecessarily
tall walls built up around him that
keeps him from
truly you know fully experiencing his
life
right so so another way to say it so
it's like tearing down walls
we're both i would say you know and to
similar degrees lenient
on our youngest kids but they are
they operate with different levels of
personal leniency
because they are different kids oh yeah
again i just think it's so much has to
do with
just the disposition of the kid it's i
don't know
the the more i parent the more powerless
i feel as a parent
i'm just being honest with you i'm just
that's i'm that's my experience
uh now this this aspect of being a
younger child
really intrigues me from uh
parody uh mithikanoy
i'm two years younger than my sister
it's a bittersweet relationship one
thing i hate about it
is all the competition all my grades are
compared to hers all my talents are
compared to that of hers
living that way for 18 years i have
learned to calculate my self-worth from
other people's achievements
it's not about what i like or what i can
do it's more about
am i better than the other person
because that is the only way my parents
will accept me
hmm um
wow okay so we've already we've talked a
lot about my competitive competitive
nature
uh we had one very
infamous podcast where i tried to
convince you that you were also
competitive
and i won that argument yeah um so
that was the joke the uh i am
and i think another way to to say it is
i definitely come from a
performance-based household right
now i i am incredibly thankful and
grateful for
the way my parents raised me and i think
i have so much to be thankful for
i do think that they had high
expectations for performance right
it was like when you brought home the
good grades and you and you
are you excelled in a sport like you
receive praise for those kinds of things
uh and so i think that
the way that my personality interacted
with that is i was like
oh i see how this game works
and i turned a lot of things into a game
and it's turned me into a
very performance-based person i'm an
enneagram three
and so i kind of enter into every single
arena
of life thinking about how i can win
right how i can come out on top of the
situation not necessarily at the expense
of other people but just like
i want to be good at this thing that i
am now engaging with right
um i've never thought about it being
anything to do with
birth order or in comparison to my
brother
until now until until this uh
observation so do you do you recall
i mean comparing yourself he was he was
older
you know i don't know if basketball is a
good example i know that you guys
both were like laser focused on
on basketball you know he was on he was
on the high school team
uh you were you you were on the jv team
as a freshman so you were never on the
same squad
one game one game state playoffs
my freshman year they pulled me up to
varsity and we were on the court
in the first round of the state playoffs
for like a few
plays and did you coach gage just did it
so that i think he just did it so they
could be like the mclaughlin boys are on
the
on the floor at the same time you would
would you did would i pass it to each
other
i mean i was a freshman i was like i've
been on jv
uh i've been on jv not starting by the
way
as a freshman oh so because your pants
because coach mace
in his great wisdom played jason batman
before me oh you're bitter
[Laughter]
i am a little bit bitter about that but
coach gage was like i don't know what
coach mace is doing but i know that
you're good and we're gonna bring you up
to varsity in your sophomore year
which he did but he also brought me up
for the for the state playoffs
so so yeah there was a you guys would be
out in your front yard on your
basketball court both
doing there was a whole lot of
competitiveness between the two of us
with whatever we were doing like playing
one-on-one
playing one-on-one playing horror some
of the most like
epic long extended
games of horse in the summertime
one-on-one games that would often end
with me
crying and running inside because i was
the younger one and i was losing most
like almost all the time until maybe
until
in high school every once in a while i
might be able to to win just because i
was getting so tall
um how tall is cole six
two okay six if okay yeah
he might have me by a couple inches um
i think that here's the thing i i don't
i think that he also might i don't know
if he knows what enneagram he is but
he's got a lot of three in him
um and so
i think that he's also an achiever and a
performer
and so i don't think again it i don't
think it was hey i'm a performer because
i was a younger sibling i think that
maybe both of us are
are that way because there was first of
all kind of pre-wired to that and then
growing up in a family that kind of
reinforced that
so we both kind of are task and
goal-oriented people
um but there was a there was a lot of
comparison
um and i i don't remember i don't
remember
like you didn't my my parents saying
things like well your brother did this
so you need to do that
i don't remember i don't remember that
you guys had a decent relationship
i mean from my perspective coming over
for sleepovers
like i would interact with cole too like
we would listen to music yes you would
he would give me the
the the ll cool j tape and you would
play the young mc
tape and you would both try to tell me
who to try to argue
which was the coolest and which made me
feel awesome
like here i was like the swing vote here
but he wasn't who did i say was cooler
young mc
i think you had the young mc tape yeah
and he had uh cool mode is cooler but
you said
koji and cool he had both of those he
you know he had he's young mc
is not cool he was cool for a moment but
no no longevity yeah your brother was
right at the time
yeah but my point is when i would come
over to a sleepover
there would be interactions like i would
expect you know i would see you two
interact it's not like he wouldn't have
anything to do with me or you
because we were like so much younger you
guys
you guys had an active relationship yeah
i mean there was a friendship component
to it right i mean it
you didn't hate each other we got into a
lot of fights i would say that
um i don't know i i i don't think we
were as emotionally
available to each other and reliant on
each other
as i would say even locke and shepard
are right like and like a shepherd have
a
much larger age difference which can
both exacerbate and help that sort of
reliance on one another
i think in their case it has
enhanced that emotional connection but i
i think that
it wasn't until we got to be adults that
we would maybe have a conversation that
was
heavy deeper and kind of went below the
surface of like
are we talking like as kids it was let's
have a conversation about
what we're doing and how we can we're
doing it better how we could do it
better
but we're not going to have a
conversation about how we feel
you know but that but that was kind of
also a family thing
for us too right and we didn't talk a
whole lot about
feelings in my family they weren't it
wasn't that feelings were bad it was
just that it wasn't something that
talking about feelings was not valued
but you did
you didn't my perspective is you didn't
have any buried
feelings with you of animosity towards
your brother
no i mean the fights that you would have
as in
you know he would pick on you about
having a crush on somebody
and then you would get really angry and
i remember him running back into his
room
and you had a stick of deodorant in your
hand
and you threw it at his door that he
just slammed in your face
and i think it made a hole in the door i
think it may have dented it
yeah and i think the thing and the thing
about that is that i was like
i'm glad i'm an only child he would see
i want to get hit with deodorant
he would see that he could get you to
join in
and that would make me very mad if he
could embarrass me recruited my friends
to be a part of this thing like
that's harder to deal with than just him
doing it but he would also do this thing
where he would this isn't something no
one really talked about this but
i've seen this with lock and shepard now
this is a older younger thing i've seen
quite a bit
he would talk about how it was going to
be so difficult for me when i got to
fill in the blank grade you'd be like
when you get to fourth grade
it's gonna rock your world and then i
would get to fourth grade and it would
be just as fun as first grade i always
loved
school and never thought that it was
difficult right and
uh so you know it never worked he never
scared you every time i would get to the
grade
it would be fine and it became a
it became this v funny like uh
recurring joke in my family it's like
well red's in seventh grade now and
he says it's okay you know so cold
definitely would warn me about things it
would
there was that would happen quite a bit
i'm super jealous of not having an older
brother
like when it comes to music is is one
thing that's why i brought that up
is that or or whatever the case whether
it's like
in any terms like my development
was stunted i believe you know when you
have an older brother like you're
talking about
you're observing cole with his
girlfriend
and figuring out you know kind of
between the lines what they're up to
you know it might be you know you're
gaining confidence that
i know this guy i live with this guy
this guy's ridiculous
if he can have a girlfriend i can have a
girlfriend you know it's like
i i had so little confidence to even
have a girlfriend
and i would and i i felt like i missed
out on that when it came to music it was
just
just exposure to cool things that were
kind of above my head or movies
you know uh yeah most of the kids who
are introducing you to the things that
are for
older kids usually have an older brother
right
like lando watches i mean
he's got a lot of stipulations about
what he'll allow himself to enjoy
again it's self-imposed but for us it's
like
again we want to watch things that we
enjoy and he's just along for the ride
you know whereas with the younger kids
when the first kids were younger
it was more just catering to things that
were age specific
but by the time you get to three it's
just like hey
you're going to be stretched a little
bit because there's other people pulling
the the the median age of this whole
group
up and they got to adapt that's not a
birth order thing that's a personality
thing because
most well in my experience personally in
my experience with my family
and what i would say is my anecdotal
evidence
most younger kids
are excited about getting to do the
things that their
their uh older siblings were not allowed
to do
like the idea of getting away with
something watching something that you're
not supposed to watch like that's
most kids are kind of like they don't
impose their own centers like lando does
and so i just think again that's not a
birth order
family dynamic thing i just think it's
like this is how
these particular kids are wired i wanted
to bring up another dynamic
um i love when we put out these um
prompts and then we get back something
that wasn't on our radar
and i'm not talking about if you're a
twin because we've made an executive
decision that
we're not talking about twins they creep
me out
yeah and i don't want to have i don't
want to have nothing to do with speaking
of the devil
so they are the twins are the result of
the devil you guys are out
triplets whoa don't get me started no
don't even say the word quadruplets
yeah oh my gosh um but i thought
this is this is great i'll bundle these
three together um
if you have a sibling with special needs
ashley tweeted i'm the youngest with
just an older brother
my brother has autism it's weird being
the youngest by
age but being treated like the oldest
for most things
i'm more of a parent than a sister to
him love my brother to death though
and wouldn't change a thing sophia
responded said being the younger sibling
of an autistic child
has been tough at times but it has also
given me compassion
and patience at the times i needed it
the most
and then caroline responded
also younger sibling i'm the youngest
but one of my older brothers is disabled
and has always needed round-the-clock
care
i'm now a special school teacher
and have a passion for helping disabled
students find purpose
i love the fact that we got these
responses to
you know to expand this conversation
it's interesting that all three of them
are younger siblings
who have an older special need
sibling obviously that's not
always the case but i think it's it's a
little more unexpected that
okay as a younger sibling you're not
getting away with more you're having
this
older sibling experience and it's it's
you know being a part of a family
dynamic like this
you you you learn things
that uh a lot of us
never have i will say the privilege of
learning expand who you are i love
you know when they're all saying i
wouldn't change it for the world
um i've grown so much as a person i've
accessed
a level of compassion and patience yeah
that develops me i mean it's
well and that's extremely difficult and
i don't have any any any personal
experience
with this but everyone that i know
who has a family member with special
needs um
has this increased
sort of appreciation for life and i
don't mean like
oh i'm so glad that i'm not in this
situation but no like
being in the relationship with a person
who has special needs has like
given them a perspective on life that is
uh
like deeper and it's not you know you
got caroline saying that
she is helping disabled students find
purpose
i also think that disabled people help
us
find purpose you know what i'm saying
like i i think that that is a
really common theme that you see
in people who have members of their
families who have special needs is that
they have
not been now first of all okay yes
in in in lots of cases maybe there is a
burden aspect to it and that this is
this is a lot of work this is a lot of
attention there's a lot of sacrifices
that are made by parents and by siblings
of course
that's an aspect i can only i can't
imagine because i don't
have that experience um but at the same
time i think that there's a huge
blessing
that comes with that and i think you're
seeing that and these
and these mythical beasts who shared as
we shift to
the only child responses you know i'm
just
very i'm just struck with
how how much you are shaped by the
environment you grow up in in terms of
like
again it's not just about birth order
but it's about additional personalities
in your home
and like the the deeply intimate level
of exposure you have
to people who are you know either adults
or
developing kids at different ages
it's just i mean it it it has
to have an impact on how you develop
at at least in the short term when
you're in that situation
you know in comparison to being an only
child
being in people's mess you know and
understanding uh
you know you just really get to know
people
when you when you're related to them and
live with them and
living on top of each other um
and yeah so i i do feel like
i missed out bree sheer tweeted
growing up being an only child was awful
uh wow i was so lonely i always wanted a
sibling and constantly annoyed my
parents to give me one
say give me a sibling um well
you know there's a process involved yeah
well a story
i have a lot of i don't recall ever
asking for a sibling i mean
you know my mom yeah because i had the
half sister and then there was the
divorce and it was just like well
it's like okay mom is single uh it's
just the two of us it just wasn't an
environment to
like hope for a sibling it's just that
it didn't seem like that was something
that was going to happen
i think maybe there are some kids that
would have been like oh i hope she gets
married and then i'll have like there'll
be a baby
like did you ever think i don't think so
yeah i don't
i don't think did you ever hang out with
babies
and think oh i would like one of these
in my house
she had a her friend donna i remember
had like this cute little toddler
daughter
and i remember like being infatuated
with her as like a
in a younger sister kind of way like
holding holding the baby or playing with
the toddler and like um
i mean i had a few baby dolls myself
um and i don't know if that was some
sort i think there was a
it was more of a uh it's so
you know these babies are so cute but
maybe there was a loneliness
thing i definitely remember being in my
room it's even when i had the
the stepsister you know the age
difference was such that like
we really didn't have a relationship i
would be in my room a lot
listening to the radio or playing with
my gi joes
you know i've told the story i i didn't
listen to the radio or music for the
longest time because
my step-sister liked music yeah i just
wanted to
differentiate yourself my myself but
yeah i mean and i was certainly lonely
and i had this
um i mean uh
sav tweeted at us sav sikvana
as an only child from harnett county
with a single mom what
just like me i felt like i was socially
behind my peers it wasn't until college
that i found and developed a personality
and opinions that were holding my
own i struggle with boundaries
of oversharing and self-isolation i
often resent
not having a sibling to confide in who
could understand exactly where i'm
coming from without the judgment that a
parent might have
even when i know my parents want the
best for me it's still a lot of pressure
and responsibility to be
a good daughter so i mean i relate to
being socially stunted i i was
you were had a voracious appetite to
spend the night at other
kids homes of any age
and that's so strange to be satiable i i
mean
as close as we became i know i was very
anxious
to go spend the night at your house or
you know other kids
homes and i rarely did it i just didn't
and then whenever i would go over and we
would interact with like the other kids
in the neighborhood
it was it was a high anxiety situation
for me
looking back on it like i just wasn't i
wasn't
used to being around a bunch of
boisterous
assertive kids i definitely remember in
preschool being afraid of all the other
all the other boys and i would hang out
with the girls because at least they
were chilled out well and you but you
also went to like a
preschool kind of daycare situation
earlier than i did
i did yeah um i did preschool
out here actually in thousand oaks was
the first
but again yeah it's funny because i
actually
am more on the introverted side as an
adult
i'm tot i'm fine with with large groups
of people and i can
adapt to it and i don't and i and i can
my anxiety can
i don't have a lot of anxiety it's just
it's not my preference my preference is
to be alone
right but it's weird that as a kid
my preference was very much like
it's almost like i got it all out of the
way it's like well we you know we and we
change over time in that way yeah
so it's not locked in that's for sure
because i would i actually consider
you i mean i i don't know you're kind of
borderline
introvert extrovert i think i i'm trying
to figure out how much this pandemic has
has influenced that about me because i
like
i'm i'm noticing that i really have to
make up my mind to get out of
my my house and my comfort zone and my
my very small plans and you know it's so
i'm in this
i'm in a transition period of like
getting back out into the world as
a lot of us are but um
back in the day as a kid i think it you
know it was i i had
i caught up but i had a lot of catching
up to do
by you know by high school and i was and
we've talked about this before but
i never perceived any of this like i did
not have
any perception that you were
uncomfortable i mean
okay yeah we went to camp carraway and
you didn't take a dump the entire week
but i was just like okay i mean it
happens
sometimes [ __ ] doesn't happen right
but i don't remember thinking like i
mean maybe my mom was like you know
lincoln's having her she she never told
me that at least i don't remember
link is really nervous about this week
and you need to help him
right i didn't have any any idea that
you were not having a great time that i
was having like every single thing that
we were doing i was just like
this is all everything about this is
awesome i tend to think that about
everything that i'm experiencing i tend
to think that yeah i inflate it and make
it
even better than it actually is before
and after
and during right i don't know where that
what that comes from but i
never had any indication that you
weren't just having
as great of a time as i was having yeah
for me it's i mean if
i try to get specific to like if you
have an older sibling who's gonna
hold you down and and drip spit from
their mouth
and dangle it onto your face never hit
my face
yeah again right a lot of control it
never hit your face so you learned it's
like this guy's
all bark no bite but for some we never
punch each other in the face
and you never punch each other in the
face we did the old charlie horse that
was that was our go-to but from
but for me you know i had to i had to
learn this out in the
with like acquaintances it's like
this person is boisterous i don't i
don't know what they're up against do
they
does this kid have a knife none of the
kids had knives
but it and i don't recall fixating on
knives
but i'm just using an example of like
you know i had to assess these things
and come to these
uh ex experience how people put on
certain ways and that that doesn't
necessarily
mean that they can back it up or that
that's that's the complete picture of
who they are
the more people you live with and grow
up with the more you realize we're all
full of [ __ ] and we're all
you know we're all putting on our masks
and protecting ourselves
because you can see through that in your
own home
i just have one person in my home for
most of my
you know growing up so i just had that
data point
but that might but the science says that
again you catch up and you're okay
i i again i just don't know how much i
mean i think that the whole
i definitely think that the whole
feeling like you're behind and like
you're oh i'm hearing this for the first
time because
i didn't have a older brother or older
sister to tell me i
that completely makes sense but the like
anxiety or i don't trust this person
i tend to think that it's just
personality sure
sure has a lot to do with it i mean i
wonder if my kids ask me
how many kids i should have i mean we're
you know we're in such
we're in such a different world now but
i think
my inclination from based on my
experience
is to not and i'm i'll even make a joke
with people sometimes it goes something
like this
uh congratulations on the new baby um
you know you need to go ahead and have
another one because you don't want to
only child you don't want to do that you
don't want to do that to your kids
it's not really a joke and then they're
like well that's what we were planning
on doing
we're in los angeles and we just want
one child i know i try not to tell
people
how many kids to have unless they ask me
and no one ever asked me so i know
you just tell them anyway if i if i'm
pressed to to give
advice it would be don't just have one
kid it's better
it's better that it's better on
everybody to have a second one except
for the parents i think
so either either don't have children or
if you're gonna have
children have two kids yeah or three
uh i'm happy that we have three
i can't imagine having four and i'm so
i mean like he he really slipped slipped
under the wire there
you know barely got through and i'm glad
i'm glad he did
but like there was no there's never ever
a point in my mind that i wish i had a
fourth kid well there are never
there are times christie sometimes seems
like she wants a baby again and i'm like
ah like i like have this well it's funny
reaction because
jesse uh i would say
multiple times a year right um
maybe she'll be a day late and then
she'll
she'll be like and she'll be like
what if i'm what if i'm pregnant like
she imagines what it would
feel like to be pregnant and uh thus far
it's been it is imagine definitely
seeing like she's staring into an abyss
of doom you can't help her with it
imagining what it would be like to be
pregnant is a good exercise because that
is
not a that's a that's a
tough experience having another child or
having a baby
is is a thing that somehow some some
people still think it's a great idea
well
so there's definitely nothing about
there's nothing from jessie that is
exceed where she's excited about it
right
and again uh i'm technic the tech
i'm very very unlikely to make my wife
pregnant at this point having
had a vasectomy not impossible but very
unlikely right
so for me it all just boils down to the
fact that i've always wanted
a daughter and my only daughter is
barbara
and i treat her like a little girl and i
talk to her about all the
that she can achieve anything that she
wants and you know
girl power all my girl power sort of
encouragement goes to my dog
and um that's kind of cool in one sense
but it's a little bit sad because
you know barbara's gonna die at some
point before she gets to be the age
where she would go off to college she's
gonna
she's gonna die yeah i'm i'm glad that
we we we experienced um
a daughter and sons and that dynamic
having a daughter first and like the the
whole bossiness we talked about like
i think that really played into like her
personality and stuff like that but like
as as opposed to having a if lincoln was
first and lily was in the middle who
knows
everything will be different maybe so i
think it all has an impact but then it
doesn't have this
lasting like deterministic impact well
speaking of twins
we can close with this uh
this this is where twins are actually
really helpful
right is and i'm not talking about like
planned
uh twin experiments but there are some
uh sort of just circumstantial
experience experiments where twins grow
up in different environments for they
got separated at birth or whatever
um i don't know the results of those
so i'm not going to speak about it but
that is the only way to know what you
just
talked about which is like well what
would lily be like if she wasn't the
oldest child
um is that she had a twin that grew up
in a different place
or better yet a triplet or a quadruplet
and they all grew up in different places
i hope nobody comes out of the woodwork
uh i mean the author of the
the book the sibling effect what the
bonds among brothers and sisters reveal
about
us jeffrey kluger said for
plenty of us the only ones left at the
end of the dance will be the ones who
brung us
the brothers and sisters who have been
with us the longest
loved us the hardest and by a wide
margin
know us the best so if you if you got a
sibling that you love
send them some love today and if you
don't we'll send you some love right now
i do think that that that's a good point
it's one thing to have parents who know
you and you know
when when you're like us and you've uh
lived sort of a a weird unexpected life
and being able to be successful in a
medium where we become these public
figures that more people know us than we
know people right
because we're of our faces being out
there
and almost everyone who has a perception
of who we are
has an incorrect perception of who we
are people incomplete
like or don't like whatever their
perception of us is a projection
that we have chosen to curate and put on
the internet now
it's pretty personal it's pretty real
but it is a curation right if you
if you're a fan of us you like us you
like you don't like
who we are and who we would be if you
were to live with us or if you would
have grown up with us
now having parents who can kind of
always ground you and always bring you
back down to
who you really are it's one thing it's
another it is another thing to have a
sibling to have someone who
is in your generation who knows exactly
who you are
and sees you for exactly who you are uh
and i think that that's something that
my brother can do can do fairly well
is when i have a conversation with him
he having a conversation with him is by
default a grounding experience right
it's not like he's trying to bring he's
not trying to ground me he's not trying
to bring me down
right but you just when you've got
somebody who
knows you apart from the curated public
image
and this could be good friends too i
mean it's one of the reasons that people
who are
like super famous celebrities who have
created sort of a cocoon of people
pleasers around them tend to be these
narcissistic monsters
um it's it it's people who regardless of
what level
of you know society they have ascended
to quote-unquote
have people who know exactly who they
are
and will tell them exactly what they
think that's a that's a healthy thing
and i think that siblings
uh you need a sibling because of that i
guess you just got me
yeah you're the closest thing i got and
we you you know we use the marriage
analogy more than the sibling analogy
because
it's um because it
you know when there's no blood then if
you get in at any moment
will there be blood we're not blood
related there will never be blood
if we punch each other in the face there
might be
okay you can deflect at this point but
i'm saying yeah there is something
different
but in our relationship than you have
with your brother because of that
um the
the the way the bond was determined like
there's something to the blood of it all
right it's like
sure it's immutable yeah
and so that and and plus he's not in
your
you know you're you're not working with
them every single day and
you know it's we're not just friends but
we've got this
business that we're you know and this
brand and everything that we're
creating together is a is a is an
extremely connecting and complicating
factor in this conversation
but that's why
you have something with coal in those
conversations that yeah i guess i don't
have anybody in that sense
and you're not it i just don't have it
maybe you can get like a brother
a brother for hire i i'm okay i'm good
enough
you know it's you can't recreate that
anyway you know i i would just rather
get my way more often in other senses
okay well
just just to play yes just to play the
the uh
the only child card so i you've got
you've got a brother
i've got the only child card okay it all
evens out
let us know what you think uh thank you
for those of the hundreds of you who
who interacted with us uh on twitter
and uh you got a wreck we'll keep the
conversation going in the meantime i do
have a wrecking effect
complete left turn unrelated to
everything that we're talking about just
a book that i'm reading
it is uh actually super relevant right
now i
i found myself wanting to read this book
because
one of the interesting things things
that has happened as we're kind of
coming out of
the uh pandemic and things are getting
back to normal is
oh what do you know mass shootings are a
thing again
in america right sadly tragically
and there's all this debate about the
second amendment and i just found myself
thinking you know i don't really i hear
people say things about the second
amendment
and i either didn't pay attention when
we talked about this in class or i was
never taught it
um and so i was like i'm going to start
maybe reading about the history of the
second amendment
and it's it's formulation
so i read this book or i'm like three
quarters of the way through it
the second amendment a biography by
michael waldman
not a brand new book i think it was
written in 2014
won some awards is highly regarded as a
great comprehensive sort of exploration
of the history of the second amendment
both the thing that was i started
realizing there was so little that i
knew
and understood about the formation
of the constitution and the bill of
rights
i couldn't i'm just going to be honest
with you i couldn't have told you
that the bill of rights was like the
first
list of amendments that was added to the
constitution after it was written i
think i could have told you that but
only that like i knew i i couldn't have
told you that
and i didn't know exactly why it
happened and what it was a reaction to
and what the concerns were at the time
i was pretty ignorant of this uh so if
you're also ignorant of it or you just
happen to be interested in this kind of
thing
i recommend it's a short read and uh
it's an easy read it's not like super
academic or anything
uh the second amendment a biography by
uh michael waldman just a nice
introduction to this which i think then
does
influence the way that we think about uh
this
very divisive
and inflamed but very important debate
that we're having in our country as
we're trying to navigate being
the country that leads in a lot of
things including
by a long shot and by a large margin
people who get killed by gun violence
the second amendment a biography
michael waldman all right y'all hashtag
gear biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best